a nevada man is asking for help from the
public in solving a 56-year-old mystery
it's a missing person's case that could
also be a murder
paul franzak gained international
attention when the i-team first reported
his story
this was back in 2013. now through a dna
test that he learned he wasn't paul
franzak after all
since then he's discovered he once had a
twin sister but she vanished
george knapp has this exclusive story
like the biggest thing was after all
these all this time of trying to find
out who i was
everything paul franzak thought he knew
about himself turned out to be untrue
when he received the results of home
dna tests back in 2012.
it set him on a double-barreled quest
one to find out what became of the real
paul franzak
a newborn baby kidnapped from a chicago
hospital
in 1964 and two to find his biological
family
and why someone abandoned him on a new
jersey sidewalk
in 1966 both of those ventures
have proven painful and both have
produced other mysteries
we were able to find out who i actually
was my biological family
and all the dark really tragic things
that happened
when i was in that situation before i
was abandoned he learned his name at
birth was jack rosenthal
his birth parents both died but other
family members confirmed that jack
and his siblings were abused and
neglected as kids
he also learned he'd been kept in a cage
with his twin sister jill
everything i've heard from other members
of my family
pretty much made it clear to me that me
and my twin sister jill were abused
neglected and ultimately i was abandoned
and if she wasn't murdered by them then
she's still out there
franzak tried to connect with his living
siblings but they rejected
all contact he searched previous
residences
dug holes looking for bones used ground
penetrating radar
in the belief that his sister jill had
been killed and buried
but no trace was ever found the story of
his search was chronicled in a book
the foundling and in our new interview
he shared an
artist version of what his sister jill
might look like
assuming she too might have been
abandoned somewhere
and grew up not knowing her true
identity that
part of the quest is still alive and
open right the question of where
the quest for jill is it's on it's it's
ongoing and i'm not going to stop till
we find her
franzak has made considerable progress
on the other quest
too the search for the kidnapped baby
the i-team reported last december
that a man living in rural michigan had
been matched through dna
to the missing franzac a news team from
our affiliate wgn in chicago
followed the trail to the town of manton
michigan where they tracked down
and spoke to this man kevin beatty whose
family members suspected he might be the
missing franzac
when their dna tests leaked out various
investigators
including the fbi came to believe that
beatty
was biological paul beatty spoke to wgn
but asked them to keep his name private
because he was struggling with cancer
wgn agreed in nevada paul franzak
also honored that request and still
won't confirm to us
that beatty was franzac but he did
confirm
biological paul was alive as of a year
ago
and told us the franzac baby did reach
out to his long-suffering mother
dora franzak he actually talked to my
mom
they actually talked quite a few times
and unfortunately he passed away kevin
beatty died in april
the franzak family sent condolences
after his passing
george knapp 8 news now the other
unanswered question is who
kidnapped the franzac baby paul franzek
says he has some solid leads but is
still trying to crack that mystery
and we have additional links on our
website